Muller and at least three other American
civilians james foley steven sotloff and
peter kassig are among thousands of
deaths blamed on Isis at its peak in
2015 the terror group controlled large
sections of Syria and Iraq Holly
Williams has covered its rise and fall
so Holly good morning
how much is Baghdadi's death likely to
damage the group he founded well good
morning well at the very least this is a
symbolic blow to Isis because remember
this is the man who stood up in a mosque
in Iraq five years ago and declared
himself the caliph or leader of a
so-called Islamic state after that split
from al-qaeda he led Isis to the peak of
their violent rampage ruling over an
estimated ten million people at one
point enslaving women carrying out
gruesome executions and exporting terror
to Europe and the US but Isis was never
about one man it is about an ideology it
is an extreme and violent interpretation
of Islam some would say a perversion of
Islam and that doesn't end with Baghdadi
and that doesn't end with Isis other
jihadist groups have replaced their
leaders quite quickly when they've been
killed and there's little doubt that
Isis will do the same one likely
successor is a character name known as
Abu Abdullah car - like Baghdadi he
apparently spent time in a prison camp
in Iraq following the US invasion of
2003 that camp became an incubator for
jihadis president Trump said yesterday
that Baghdadi's Caliphate has been quote
obliterated and it's true that Isis lost
control of its last remaining patch of
territory in Syria in March but the
Pentagon's watchdog says that Isis still
has up to 18,000 members in Syria and
Iraq and in eastern Syria that's the
area from which President Trump ordered
US troops to withdraw this month Kurdish
forces say they're holding up to 12,000
accused Isis fighters an American
general described those prisoners to me
last month as a quote contained fighting
force
so Baghdadi is dead but Isis is still
very much alive Gail right more work to
be done there thank you very much Holly
Williams reporting from Istanbul